usually I begin everywhere I possibly
can by taking a concept and giving you a
picture first and try to apply intuition
to see okay well what do things look
like and what might be answered beat now
in this case I'm actually going to do it
in reverse I'm gonna do it the rigorous
proving you know everything with the
algebra way first and then we'll get to
the picture and you'll be like oh of
course
okay so if we want to do calculus before
we get to integration first we need to
know a derivative okay so here is the
simple question I'm going to pose here
is the simple question I'm going to pose
to you once we get sine X colors is
defined in terms of sine and ten is
defined in terms of sine and cos so once
we get sine really everything we'll just
kind of pull that from them okay sure
how we go about doing this
hmm differentiation from the very
beginning right from the very beginning
we began with like defining the
derivative in terms of the gradient
function do you remember that it's all
about gradient okay
so therefore what do we have to do if we
want a derivative of something how do we
bring gradient into place what do we use
right in the beginning we use first
principles right we did gradient so rise
over run yeah
so this thing here is a function this is
my f of X so the definition of first
principles is the limit as H approaches
zero now what's usually on the numerator
we usually took twenty in terms of F so
f dash right so what's gonna be on the
normal you run f of X plus h take away
and VIX that's your that's your I'm
sorry that's your prize isn't it that's
your eyes but here I've defined f of X
is sine of X so therefore on my
numerator there's f of X plus h and
there is f of X yeah looking good
now you can see before I go any further
why I needed to do like when we need to
treat expansions way back this is part
of the reason why it's not just like oh
cool I can do sign up you know 30 plus
45 degrees that's kind of just a
sideshow this is really where it was
heading okay
and of course we divide by the run okay
now since we know how to expand these
compounding sort of results I'm just
going to take sine of X plus h and I'm
just going to quote the identities what
identity will I get sine X plus h plus
great will keep the angles in the same
order X's and thinner HS and then I have
this sine X now you look at this and you
think okay that's a bit of a mess where
can I go with this now what you ought to
be thinking is what have we learned
already that will help us deal with this
okay and I want you to point out to you
four it says just as one little item
right look at this guy do you see that
do you see him should make you really
really suspicious right you're like huh
if I could do something with that then I
can work with this thing okay now that's
the first thing there are other clues
lying in this so what I need to do is
notice that I have a whole series of
terms that are connected to H that
connected to the limit and then I have
other terms that are not connected to
the edge they are independent of H which
terms are those
I know this guy yep what else is
independent that going there and one
more this kind of you so what I need to
do is disentangle them from what's
happening with the limit to do with H
okay so here's the way I'm going to do
it I noticed right from being is these
two side terms so let's get them out of
the way first let's say I've got limit
as H approaches 0 and if I take sine x
out as a factor from those two terms I'm
gonna get this guy sine X outside of
this do you agree on that like that's me
factoring out those 2 sine X terms now I
could tank on this next video here but
because I've got a sine X thing
happening and cos x thing happening and
actually gonna deal with them as
separate limits the limit of a sum is
the saber is the sum of the limits so
I'm just gonna separate this out from
one limit into two so he's one of my
fractions and he's my other one
okay I hope the wheels are turning here
right I can do a couple of things here
the whole point of identified in green
the terms that are independent of age is
to say we know what they're completely
unaffected by those limits as H
approaches zero okay nothing to do this
so I can remove them out from the limits
in exactly the same way that what we
don't understand when you are
integrating something like this right
that - he doesn't care what's happening
whereas X has you know
Drex integrating whatever that's why you
can pull him out the front or in the
exactly the same way sine X and call it
X they don't care what this limit is
doing so I'm going to extricate them out
of this it means take it out from all
the other stuff it's okay and now
they're separate okay so now look at
this carefully with me the first thing
that we saw as a clue up here in red
should be screaming issue right what is
that equal to this is one now just pause
for a second for a second I want us to
remember why it is one okay you might
remember doing this circular geometry
thing with great in a minute that's one
reason the other reason which is more
about how these things behaving as H
approaches zero what's sine H
approaching 0 as H approaches zero
what's the denominator approaching also
zero right but the critical thing is
they are both approaching zero at the
same rate at the same rate that's why
the ratio is going to turn into a 1 - 1
which is 1 okay so I'm gonna write that
down percent that's good then I want you
to look over here have a look at this
other limit what's happening here for
instance as H approaches zero what's
this doing where is it going
I can but I'm deliberately not for a
reason we become carriers what's
happening to this now cause H we know
what caused a she looks like it's going
towards one so therefore it's going
towards one take way one which is zero
right this is going to zero
what's happening to the denominator also
going towards zero so therefore isn't
reasonable to conclude that since that
is doing the same as this is it also
equal to one the answer is it is not but
how do we show that how do we reason
through like on the way that I've showed
them that both look like they're going
to zero zero so why not they both equal
the same thing okay I'm going to appeal
to a picture now okay now maybe we just
want to go this off on the side in a
small way okay now first let's just get
a picture for what this one looks like
sign H over H right so here is the same
curve and he is the expert yeah so you
can see they're both approaching sinner
but they're approaching the same rate
yes okay now flex your trip graphing
muscles a teeny bit not the plus h but
the whole numerator it is the COS graph
which way sekolah it's shifted downward
yeah take away one okay
so therefore rather going from negative
one to one it's going from negative 2 to
0 yes so looks something like that
you heard that so there's cos h minus 1
you can see it's approaching 0 and then
you've got this guy this that graph now
you have a look if both approaches your
but it's qualitatively different from
what's happening here do you see that
for instance seeing as cos h minus 1 has
a stationary point there at the origin
right that means that over here like
compare compare these values here with
these values up here
clearly the cos h minus 1 graph is
really really small much faster than the
h graph needs do you see that so either
they're both approaching 0 this guys
getting hit drastically faster it's
always smaller does that make sense
so that's why these guys both
approaching zero at the same rate so I'm
going to write this down as one alright
that's what I'm getting out of this than
at you okay but this time they're both
approaching zero but the top guy he's
like he leaves the determinant
denominator in the dust he hits the zero
so much faster that this turns into zero
does that make sense you see how I
reasoned that visually so this means I'm
not the sign X at the front that was
independent of the limit and then you've
got because X out here also independent
of the limit so what's that it's just
cause now that was not too difficult
because we had a lot of the pieces
already prepared we already knew this
therefore we could we're equipped to
deal with this and we also have the
tricky expansions to blow everything out
in the first place okay so this time now
we're done with the ah drop draw me a
picture
draw me a nice decent sized one of sine
X that's what we just depreciated
always bigger than you think
okay mine's a bit lopsided but you get
the idea okay now how do I look at my
side XK right in a new color they are
doing great in new car and I'm gonna die
just to make it really clear I'm going
to draw the cos curve on top of it what
this is telling me is that this is the
grain function of this let's see what
that means
now the extension one extension to
students I began with this before
because it's a quick somewhat intuitive
argument wasn't a proof at all this was
a proof but you have a look now right
think about some critical points for
instance I can see on the sine curve the
most important features with regard to
calculus are probably the two stationary
points right now when you have a
stationary point on a curve on the black
curve what does that mean about your
derivative for stationary points is it
zero right which is exactly what you see
at X is equal to PI on two right
you've got the site X curve having its
first stationary point and you've got
close X cause plan to of course is zero
and the second station point over here
three plans to again you've got that
marrying up what else do you see that
you can conclude for instance remember
how we said oh look the gradient of X
and the gradient of sine X they're both
approaching the same thing if they go
towards the origin do you see that what
is the actual value of the gradient it's
one cuz that that green line is my
gradient function right so it's one no
one time wonder no wonder these things
are fishing the same thing at the same
rate because the gradient of course of y
equals x is 1 1 and the gradient of sine
x at that point is also 1 so if I drew a
tangent line here it wouldn't that be
why it was that other things you can
keep noticing for example on this
polygraph that I've shown I've got
increasing and increasing in the middle
here is where I'm decreasing right in
fact that's a point of inflection is it
not how do you know I know it's a point
of inflection
yeah that's right I've gone this is
concave down and this becomes concave up
which corresponds to the derivative
turning around like this which I'm going
to show once I get the dirty thing okay
you can keep on rotating inside either
but the important thing is the pitching
you can see how God